[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to with far from home
closing the lid on Phase three of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe eager fans are
looking ahead to the future but what
could be coming down the line throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that we know so far about
phase four of the film franchise as well
as giving my theories on what could
happen in the movies going forward this
is full spoilers ahead so if you don't
want any of the big surprises ruined
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
I hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of phase
four of the MCU
okay so firstly let's look at what phase
four will be about thematically whilst
endgame would have been the perfect
closing chapter on this section of the
Marvel Universe studio heads have for
one reason or another appointed
spider-man far from Punk to be the final
film whilst this may have some fans
scratching their heads we've actually
seen something similar to in the MCU
already that showcases why this is
happening
though many may think that phase 2
closed for the age of Ultron it was
actually ant-man that was the final film
and Kevin Feige stated that this was
done on purpose because power things at
itself paid off down the line ant-man of
course introduced the quantum realm as
well as extra dimensions and these had a
huge effect on Phase three dimensions
played a big part of Doctor Strange and
the quantum realm was probably the most
important plot device in Avengers and
game that allowed the titular heroes to
save the universe going forward we know
that Spider Man far from home will
introduce the multiverse with Mysterio
being from another dimension and thus
it's a safe assumption to make that
things in Phase three will center around
this so what movies are slated to be
released during this phase well we know
for definite that Black Widow is due to
be released next year and it's prequel
film will tell your origin story the
film will star Rachel Weis and most like
widows mental as well as foreign spew
who is playing a rival assassin and
likely be the big bad villain of the
piece she is reportedly yelling at Bella
over who has been described as a moral
opposite to Widow and will likely be the
reason that the character decides to
vacate her position and join shield in
addition to this David Harper and ot [ __ ]
Ben Lee which are probably pronounced
horribly are also set to star in the
film though details of their casting are
still unknown we will likely learn
willows father's name which was teased
in endgame so that could be Harbor and
the movie is set to be released in June
next year followed by an unknown project
in November so that's the confirmed one
out the way but what about the rumored
films well Roger Waddell who leaked
several major plot elements of endgame
to Twitter recently discussed the film's
already in development before we get
into those I'm gonna show some Waddell's
tweets so that you know he's an
authentic source
these include door being fat which
posted in December along with Jarvis
appearing as a cameo in the film and
cementing himself as the first character
to make a switch from TV to film Waddell
also posted about the hail Hydra scene
and stay that the elevator and the cast
of characters from that in Winter
Soldier made a reappearance and more and
more and more basically ruined the whole
film so yeah they are pretty much 100%
right now so I'm giving you one more
chance to turn off the video before I
discuss the big plot elements of
guardians of the galaxy 3 and more are
you still here ok good so guardians of
the galaxy picks up with Thor as a
member of the crew and it centers around
them searching for Gamora
they've been several rumors that beat
array bill will make an appearance in
the film - which would set up the as
guardians of the galaxy as well as the
following plot elements which Waddell
tweeted Rockets creator is the High
Evolutionary Drax is in for a big
surprise when he discovers his daughter
is alive rocket also gets a love
interest in the form of Lila nebula and
star-lord will grow into closer friends
the High Evolutionary is reportedly the
main villain and apparently was the
creator of beer a Belle - Zac Efron is
rumoured to be playing at a warlock who
due to the events of endgame will have
had five years to mature in his powder
that was teased in the post-credits
scene of the prior
James Gunn has written and is directing
the film and it's set to make a big mark
on the Marvel Universe with Gamora
gradually introducing the idea of
alternate timelines and realities
springboarding of this is black panther
- ryan coogler has signed on again to
write and direct it and there's also
been confirmation by the cast and crew
that Michael B Jordan will be returning
so this will likely be on the spiritual
plane
this film will follow what kinda
introducing their technologies to the
rest of the world and probably showcase
that this may have dire consequences
with it falling into the wrong hands
after this comes Doctor Strange -
directed by scott derrickson who's at
the helm of the first film this movie
will center around the battle between
strange and mortal who at the end of the
prior film had just begun hunting
Wizards Lord Nightmare will also make an
appearance and tried to play the two off
against each other
Marvel execs have reported that strange
is set up to become one of the new
anchors of the MCU
and he will likely be drafted into
working with the Avengers at the end of
the film following Doctor Strange - is
the eternal starring Angelina Jolie and
directed by Khloe's now the film is
reported to push further into the cosmic
side of the MCU and for those who don't
know the Eternals are a race of
extremely powerful immortal beings think
of Superman times 100 and you get the
idea it primarily used to fight their
foes the deviants and they massively
open up the scope of the MCU perhaps
introducing Galactus and more richard
madden has been rumored to be involved
in the film and this could be playing
Icarus the group's leader this will
definitely add another layer to the
already expansive dimension of the MCU
deal Swift and it opens up endless
possibilities in addition to this other
films apparently part of the slate of
shang-chi mystical martial artists
that's bound to get the bad taste of
Iron Fist out of everyone's mouth
Mandarin is rumoured to be his father
and this will of course tie back into
Iron Man 3 Thor 4 will center around
adventures between the character and
beta ray bill after he's introduced in
guardians 3 Ant Man 3 Captain Marvel 2
New Avengers young Avengers and Dark
Avengers are also set to follow the
characters that been confirmed
Disney Plus shows such as Loki vision
Scarlet Witch Bucky and Falcon art is
said to be interacting with the movies
and these television offshoots will
massively play into the universe two
weeks reports say that whilst we aren't
getting another infinity Saga we are
getting several mini arcs that will span
three to six films thus allowing more
Marvel big names to be introduced such
as Doctor Doom and more however the big
bad of the MCU is expected to take the
form of Norman Osborn who will firstly
be teased in the post-credits scene
apart from home in the wake of Tony
Stark's death and the five-year time gap
that is now in the film franchise Osborn
has risen to power and he will become
the main antagonist that basically works
as Tony Stark did for The Avengers but
for super villains Osborn will be arming
them and thus create a wealth of new
enemies for the characters to face off
against the character has reportedly
purchased Avengers Tower and will use
this as his base of operations whilst
this sounds amazing
unfortunately Deadpool will not be
making an appearance in spider-man 3 and
this was announced by Ward L as false
after phase 4 we will reportedly finally
get to the x-men and Fantastic Four and
whilst I'd love to see them in the next
phase of the Marvel movies studio execs
are reportedly holding off to put some
distance between themselves and the Fox
incarnations this is probably the smart
thing to do and there's a hell of a lot
to look forward to in the upcoming films
obviously I love to hear your thoughts
on the news and if it's gotten you hyped
for phase four comment below and let me
know and if you love this video 3,000 -
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the
timeline of endgame
would you be linked at the end it covers
all of the major questions that you may
still have about the movie and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want some things cleared up I'll leave
that in the end screen so make sure you
give it a watch right after this this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]